so my name is laughs I'm not the
engineer at full fact there'll be free
parts of the stock first I wanted useful
facts then I will talk about specific
and LP problem they're trying to
automate in the end I'll talk about
transfer learning and you know if you're
not interested in journalism or politics
then hold on till the end there'll be
some useful tools you can use it your
work to solve your own NLP problems okay
so before introduce full fact allow
others to introduce our work so does
anybody recognize this man yes okay who
what's his name there Jim will be yes
what does he do he's a journalist he's a
BBC presenter every week he presents BBC
panel show called question time it goes
to different areas of the UK and their
local people from the area they ask
questions to politicians about something
that happened at that week it's a
political TV debating show this is what
he has to say as a panelist tonight
called film fact full-fat is an
organization which specializes in
fact-checking claims made by politicians
in the media so the Parana better watch
out so yeah what is it that full fact
that the panel of BBC you know question
time should watch out so first of all we
write fact-checking articles so that
articles on important issues in public
life and we always include links to
primary sources so we don't ask people
to take our word for it we allow people
to check our workings and we always show
our workings in there so if some of you
had a week off and you wanted to
research some particular public issue
that some that's the kind of work that
you would do yourself but we just you
know save your time and publish a nice
summary of that but we've links to all
the primary sources and you can go in
this government published published
Excel spreadsheet and check it for
yourself
secondly we submit Corrections if you
find something that has been incorrectly
reported we try to stop it from
spreading and you go to the source and
try to correct it in that original
newspaper we are the reason that several
newspapers in UK have correction columns
and thirdly we work with people who
produce the data like the government
statistic or service for example and we
make sure that we help them to produce
it in a clear way in the way that is can
be interpreted in a way that is actually
being
collected and not prone to
misinterpretation top well like we gave
training to BBC on how BBC should
present the data in their programming or
like we have a project with Office of
National Statistics
to produce data in a machine-readable
way which a lot of people in this room
can probably excited it'd be nice if the
data just came in not in a PDF but in a
something which is an API wouldn't that
be great
so organizationally we are a UK's
independent fact-checking charity so we
are funded by donations and we are
independent in terms of our funding like
there's no such thing as mutual money
you know hopefully you'll agree all the
money comes through some kind of bias of
it that's why we keep our funding
sources very diverse some of our funding
comes from people individual people who
just donate ten pounds a month someone
who comes from big charitable
organizations like the novel trust some
of it comes from corporations like City
of London Corporation or else Roy's some
of it comes from campaigning
organizations like 38 degrees but none
of them actually have a big proportion
in a funding that's why we can stay
independent and have our own voice and
not just do what the funders want us to
do secondly we are impartial political
neutrality is very important to us we
keep a tally of the things after
articles that you brought based on
statements of politicians and from which
party they came from so we try not to be
biased in our selection of things that
we've write about you're very yeah we're
trying to stay neutral in our output we
also have safeguards at individual
employees level people who work with
full facts are very restricted in the
political activity that they can do in
fledged clap opinions that they can
express and thirdly we have a board of
trustees who come from politics and from
outside of politics those of them who
come from politics they are from all
major political parties we have members
of House of Lords from Conservative
Party if number Labour Party from Lib
Dem some cross party members as well and
that that way we can stay impartial and
that way people can yeah that way we can
stay neutral in our fact-checking work
and it's very important to be a source
that people can trust in this kind of
work
thirdly by effective we submit
Corrections for the work that we do we
also try to influence policy in the UK
with we submit you know advice to policy
decisions that have been made and we try
to change long-term the culture of
public life in the UK like in we would
like to see a future where when you hear
politicians say something on TV you can
be sure that it comes from a trustworthy
source that information that they're
using it actually comes from specific
statistics which has been published and
you know and it can anybody can check
that would be a nice world to live in to
be a nice way to contact public life in
the country okay so let me demonstrate
what we do in one specific example so
there was in April 2014
before the you random there was a TV
debate that David David dimpled the
David Dimbleby was the presenter of the
debate and there was debate between two
politicians and one of them said seventy
percent of UK laws are made in the
European Union and other than said seven
percent of laws are made in the EU you
can probably remember which one was
which
and they spoke about it for two minutes
and then David Dibble said ok next
question and then they moved on so you
know like is it 70 percent of seven like
who thinks it's seventeen you raise a
hand nobody nobody thinks it's 70
percent of UK laws come from Brussels
one person okay one two three four okay
what about seven percent who things are
just seven percent okay a lot okay
that's interesting
so like wouldn't it be nice if there's
some kind of database of facts what
would be nice if it just like you know I
could look it up it's like 70 or seven
if it was just you know one source of
truth like wait here at PI day to London
we all want to use machine learning to
change the world for the better
you know surely the science can help
here you know there's a lot of things
that we can do would it be amazing and
unfortunately like this is not yet
possible unfortunately like even humans
are struggling at this task confined and
I was true and false you know was black
and white like when you really
superhuman level III like maybe human
level I can do this but like superhuman
level I would probably solve it so
years there'll be nice database of facts
and you can you know comfortably walk
through street knowing what's true and
false but right now it's impossible
unfortunately and let me illustrate on
this one specific question so according
to research published by the House of
Commons library the range here is
between 13 and 62% like any answer
between these two is correct so it's
like a 50% range this confidence
interval is so big you know like how can
it be how can it be this two big numbers
and the problem is that there's a word
law here and there's no mathematical
definition of the term law a lot of
rules and UK that we have to obey and
depending on which one of them's we call
law you get a different answer so if you
look at the big fish look at the things
which I decided by Parliament think
things I signed up by ministers and you
look at how many of them mentioned
specifically we have to do it in UK
because you told us so that will be 13
percent 3 percent of laws passed by
Parliament to ministers in UK explicitly
referenced they you
that's one number on the other hand if I
look at the small fish if I look at you
know quotas from imports of Moldovan
milk which are you know enforced on the
territory of UK as part of the EU if I
look at this you know tiny half a page
and maybe one page documents that's
where I get 63% and these are the things
which can be decided in UK maybe by a
local City Council and they're in this
comparison I'm comparing a 300-page
document establishing NHS to half a page
document about quarters of Moldova milk
and comparing them together and they all
both have equal weight in that
comparison so how do I compare one
thought to another it's not you know and
I'll be engineer of course this number
of pages definitely but like it could be
you know impacting people's lives and
how do I measure that you know so
unfortunately that's very hard to answer
this question and that's a lot of
effects you read them and it's like okay
it's like which way is it you know it's
all very gray and this is really a lot
of our job is like that we are inserting
the shades of grey when politicians are
campaigning in black and white they have
to say you know in very charismatic
strong statements and in reality you
know it's a you have to give the whole
posterior distribution not just a point
estimate to use a statistical metaphor
here you know we tell you what the
world is like and it's usually it's
complicated okay
so it is complicated you know like but I
work in the automation department a full
fact like I'm gonna be engineer I should
do something for it
and like what should I do and of course
finding out truth it's a hard difficult
question and there are more manual the
menial no boring task with fact checkers
every day and should really focus on
them and relieve the difficult questions
to humans and just automate the simple
things yeah so what are the simple
things in fact checking process so this
is the fact checking process firstly
monitor we watch this TV debate between
two politicians and you know this is a
speech comes in usually it's lighter
than the text and then in this text I
can support claims if I hear something
that I brought an article about two
weeks ago I can just tweet it out and
publish it immediately for something new
I can take a note let me publish it
tomorrow or next week so this how it
works I monitor I spot the claims write
write about them and finally publish so
the first two steps are definitely
automatable I can convert speech to text
nowadays in 2018 quite well and I can
extract claims from them and this is
what I will talk about in this talk how
to spot claims in text the third step is
automatable in some cases if it's about
number of laws you know how to automate
that you know just any number between 14
and 62 is correct you know that's a
doesn't really tell the whole story but
there's some some cases where it's very
clear like number of legal immigrants in
UK in 2017 like that statistics is
available it's machine readable like I
can I can do that that's fine so
specifically the task could I'll talk
about today is how to spot new claims so
input an algorithm is a document text an
output I want to highlight a list of
claims in it one two three four four
four five like the claims which are
mentioned by in that document so we've
done some research on this and we found
something about political TV in the UK
so we've found this yeah like we found
the TV show that has the most claims
there's like one show where people just
throw statistics around each other and
this is pretty cool so has anybody seen
any of this shows actually
anyone okay one two oh wow
I haven't seen any of them until I
started work for full fact so that's
fine if you haven't seen any that's
right
has anybody seen all four of them okay a
lot of political geeks in the audience
that's exciting
okay so which one do you think is the
most like heavy in terms of statistics
like which one people throw claims
around any suggestions yeah question
time okay one for question time you
think Prime Minister's Questions is
number one okay
any other ideas okay so the top one
could be premisses questions or question
time two options okay so let's see so
premises questions is the most heavy so
you're right like 42% of all sentences
setting premises questions are actually
claims average per ministers questions
is about half an hour to 45 minutes it's
about 350 sentences in there and the
third of them are claims so we got about
a hundred claims in in in the single
program question time is below that and
the Andrew Marr show is yeah it's very
very far away and this is a bridge over
three to six episodes and you know like
I can t recover just like this is my
data so of course it has to be a box
plots and like this is a box plot and
this flavor box but that I use here is
the black line in the middle
the dark line is the median so it is the
middle of the data the size of the box
is bottom 25% so the first quantile and
then the top of the box is the third
quartile and the whiskers the see no
ends ends of it this is the minimum in
the maximum so and the dots that you see
on the screen the individual episodes
because for Prime Minister's Questions
we looked at six episodes and the Manoel
annotated them and we got a small spread
for them the question time on elated
five episodes and you can see a spread
for them in there as well
but suddenly politics we only did one
and then and it turned out to be quite
low it's only 8% but I cannot report on
it because it's not very reliable data
you know I can't be spreading unreliable
later it's you know it's only it's Mon
show is not significant cool any
questions about this amazing box plot
yeah yeah like they're in different
leagues yeah I'm sure the producer
firmness questions has a target
okay so we annotated claims I haven't
really told you what claims are yet and
now we'll just time to define it so in
that's some nuances to what it claim is
but in black and white
it's a quantity and it's usually a
quantity in the past to present you can
in fact check claims about the future
unfortunately but we can't talk about
what happen in the past usually
published by some government department
that's the kind of source that usually
check an example is this government has
spent 3 billion pounds on reorganization
of the NHS and some numbers in the past
which we cannot check or just not
interesting to check if somebody says
I'm a qualified social worker qualified
for over 20 years
there's the 20 years there's a quantity
in there but it's someone's personal
history it's only public interest and
it's not public information usually so
we don't check these things so this is
what we are looking for in the documents
that's what my algorithm should detect
out there and to collect the
sanitation's we use the tool called
prodigy it's a self hosted annotation
tool you don't have to go to Mechanical
Turk or cloud flower you can just post
it on your own servers and it's created
by the team behind Spacey - one tiny
Matthew honeybell who created amazing
can help you library called spacing and
this is a annotation tool it wasn't
better in autumn you should all check it
out and use prodigy it's quite nice it
has different UIs this is just one you
either to use you can annotate images
know different things with it
there's a nice you know swipe left and
right annotation interface which is
really cool so this is a view annotators
view they recruited 80 volunteers to
help us in this task they just did it
because they like full fact and they
like to contribute this is the screen
that they saw the sentence highlighted
in yellow is the sentence you're
supposed to decide on the option number
two is quantity in the past the present
this is most of the claims fall into
that category and then there are the
categories in there which some claims
belong to some times
you also see the previous two sentences
which are not highlighted in yellow and
this is a poor man's core references
Ellucian you know Akron's dissolution is
when you see the word it he or she you
want to understand what it refers to so
here it says what it is is this it takes
people in Germany for days to produce
people in UK takes four days to produce
so what it is is this like it here
refers to the word challenge the
productivity challenge and if I used you
know neural carafe or some other
conference library I would have replaced
it by square brackets previous challenge
but I was too lazy to do that and seen a
model doesn't always work so just give
you previous two sentences and that way
you understand what the sentence is
about
and just give you some context and this
is you know poor mask reference that way
so we collected 25 thousands of such
annotations over six weeks and we every
sentence was annotated five times and I
all looked at once we had good agreement
and we got a thousand positive examples
a thousand claims from these twelve
hours of live TV and we got forty five
hundreds of negative examples things
which are not claims most of the things
that we hear in political program is
actually not a claim where it's good or
bad it's up to you to decide I mean
politics is not just about statistics
politics is about ideology people's
believes what's important so it's it's
not it is this is fine I'm not worried
that there's not so much et sticks on to
you but what I'm really worried about is
that I have leading small data like my
data set has forty five hundred rows
this is like not circle so what should I
do
you know like what what do you do when
you have a small data set and the best
thing you can do is see you which is
called transfer learning and so you find
some problem which has millions of of
data points and you train in some model
on that and from that you know
well-trained model you extract the core
of it just the core knowledge the
essence and it take that part and apply
to a problem you just finish it off if
training on your tiny data set that's
what you do that's called chance for
learning the Train on what has a lot of
data and apply to something that has
little data so a lot of you could
actually probably use transfer learning
NLP already like and in the form of
pre-trained word vectors so in past you
know since 2014 there's a lot of pre
trained word vectors available online
through to download
unless were to bag this glove this
fostex pre-trained models out there so
anybody used pre-trained word vectors
can you raise a hand okay awesome
you probably use google news like this
giant multi gigabyte file may be used
fast X train in Wikipedia or something
like that so there's a really good
models
the problem is sentences so like claim
is a sentence and the sentence has you
know ten fifteen maybe five words and
how do I get a vector for a sentence
when I have ten word vectors what do I
do and the simplest thing I can do is
average in them out you know like
there's some more advanced techniques
like you know tf-idf weights averaging
but the most naive is just averaging
them out and that's what we had to do so
far but you know strains eighteen now
there's a new thing called sentence
embeddings and there's a way to download
it send this embedding from the web and
you can just plug them in and you get
some sentence meaning out this called in
for sent it senpai torch it's produced
by Facebook I research specifically Alex
Cano and it seems to work quite well on
my model so it's not just a paper it's
also a github repo with code you can see
the Python code behind it and it's
embeddings available to download for
english language and you know when some
papers come out and they have amazing
results but there's no code with them or
no embeddings and it means I have to
spend you know and we coating it and
another five hundred dollars on GPUs to
train this embedding this is annoying
this is really nice that the Alex has
shared the entire thing with us it's
also a bit risky because you know people
can find bugs in your code and then
report them and like you know there's
some questions about some of the max
bullying coding here it's produces
different results than in the paper but
still it's fine like still your finger
style just numbers are slightly
different but I'm very grateful people
put that stuff on github you know if you
want to share an academic and you want
to publish a paper please put it on
github as much as you can I mean this is
probably everybody agrees on that and PI
data conference
so this is what infrasound looks like it
is a vilest TM it's a very popular
architecture it's been around since 2005
I will talk more about architecture
later but like by the stamps have been
using LP quite widely like there's
nothing magical in here and the max
building plastic layer is also very
simple but I'll talk more about the
architecture in a second so first let me
talk about the data like what's the data
that went to train this sentence
abetting model so the input layer here
is the word vectors and the glove word
vectors that train on eight hundred and
forty billion words so this is just
common crawl this is collected from a
lot of webpages around the internet from
yeah many years of crawling the Internet
and this is unsupervised learning you
can train from billions of words easily
just if there's two words appear
together in my text of the Internet then
it should appear together in my 300
dimensional vector space that's word
glove basically trains for you and it's
it's just similar to word Tyvek just
academics like it more it's the more
explicit algorithm it's not this last
blast my less black magic in glove than
import avec so this is the input layer
then there's a neural network and this
neural network was training supervised
tasks and that's where they took a
million of sentence pairs and they
compared them on an intial natural
language inference task I will explain
what analyte task is in my next slide
and then this wanted to see is it
actually universal like what the thing
that you get this incentives embedding
does it work for all tasks and they
tried it on text categorization
sentiment analysis and ten ten other
tasks as well and they seem to do better
than other architectures better than
commercial neural nets better than
detention networks the simple by les TM
came out on top and that's why they
published it so what is a thing that the
trained out what is this natural
language inference task and this is how
they teach computers how to think I mean
that's what rightly practices but the
thinking is quite simple usually so
given a premise like remember your logic
classes premise hypothesis so given the
premise two dogs are running through a
field how likely do you think is this
hypothesis there are animals outdoors so
is it entailment
is it
definitely true is it neutral might be
true which is contradiction definitely
false so which one do you think it is so
does that mean Frank it's definitely
false might be true might be Turkey one
person might be true okay definitely
true maturity why is it definitely true
can you tell me because the animals
outside okay yeah like that dogs animals
fields are usually outside it could be
indoor field who knows I don't know but
this is the kind of things that you want
if computers can solve this task then
they are thinking specifically how this
data set was created Stanford
nli data set they took a large
collection of photos called Flickr 40k
then they threw away the photos and just
kept the captions to this photos and it
showed these captions to people and ask
people on Mechanical Turk to write out
free sentences so if you have said
assignment says dog two dogs are running
for a field have to write three
sentences out one it is definitely true
the animals outdoors second one might be
true some puppies are running to catch a
steak it could be you know two old dogs
running to the owner who knows so but it
might be true or what something
definitely Falls the pets are sitting on
a couch this couch usually inside and
they're not running sitting this is how
this data set was created and this is
what infrasound has been trained on to
think about such things and this is the
you know the cutting edge of machine
reasoning right now it's like caption to
a photo level you know man is eating an
apple like this kind of things reasoning
about such simple things which can be
described by a photo so it's not very
advanced reasoning but this is somewhere
to start it's a toy problem I story
problem two training models on okay so
first thing people notice when they look
at this is that they are two ways to
read the sentence first you dated
forward and you read it backwards so
what happens here so the sinus has four
words the movie was great
and you take the glove vector for every
word and the first layer reads it as
their movie was great the second
backwards layer
raise it as great was movie that so
treated backwards and that sounds like
cheating you know like I'm telling the
model the future
and she retakes forward many read the
text backwards and of course I don't
read a book like that when I read a book
I just go in a straight line and that's
actually wrong if people done eye
tracking studies on how people read and
if it's a sarcastic sentence you go back
and forth a lot of times because you
just don't believe it and you just like
subconsciously read it back and forth
and some things that I say for example
only makes sense to you when I go to the
end of my sentence so it's actually how
humans read it's not cheating it's a
nice intuition about cognition that you
have to go backwards and forwards anyway
this is a biased iam the last layer here
is called max pooling and this is a way
to create one fixed weight vector from a
sentence of four words or ten words of
20 words it doesn't matter how long the
sentence is my output vector is always
the same fixed width so how do I do that
you know network produces four vectors
one for every word they are the vertical
ones of the X's in the in the graph and
have to create one thing from them and
regardless of their length of my
sentence and this is how my exploding
works have a vector for they're just
free one five a vector from movie five
at 7 4 Vols it's 1 0 1 so I have this
four vectors and the max bowling
operation just takes the maximum in
every dimension so the first dimension
what should I choose out of three five
and three I choose 5 it's the biggest in
absolute value number and for the second
dimension I choose 8 because its biggest
out of one eight zero zero and that way
I always produce the vector of the same
length as my output of max blink and
it's also quite nice because I can see
where do my maximums come from in this
case they come from the words moving in
great so two of the bold number sign
movie and one bold number isn't great so
these are the most important words in
that sentence you know and it does make
sense to me like there involves the just
exhilarating things I don't really need
them that much and you can make nice
graphs from it some places the sentence
I'm a man plays an instrument an
instrument and plays are the most
important words here if you have
logistic regression on top of that you
can combine it your logistic regression
coefficients and see what the words in
my positive class whatever to my
negative class and you can add some
interpretability
to your algorithm
cool so coming back to my task actually
try this algorithm on my task of claim
detection and so just to remind you I
have a document coming in and I want to
highlight all the claims in my document
so the two metrics that I used precision
and recall and easiest way to understand
them is by understanding two types of
mistakes that the model can make first
of all it can say that chocolate is
great is a claim you know like I wish
that it was a universal knowledge that I
could you know flag check the chocolate
is great I believe in it I think all
people should believe in it but
unfortunately there's no quantity in
here it's not like you know
fact-checking well maybe it's not good
for you actually
I don't know and it's as money's taken
can make say something which is not a
claim can become a claim and this is
wrong so your list of claims will be
polluted this would be nice a second way
it can go wrong is if it says that three
hundred fifty million a week for the U
which is the biggest claim here the
Redbus claim as it's colloquially known
is not a claim when something is
obviously a claim has been mislabeled as
a claim so the first one is called the
precision mistake where results my
results are not so precise okay my food
and the second thing is called a recall
mistake is when there are some claims
which did not make it to my list did not
make to the output of my model and this
is upsetting which is something I will
never see you know my users want to see
all the claims which are there in the
document so this is boxplots again for a
precision recall of several models that
I tried so the one in orange is in
percent and this is the top one so the
sentence the benning's do actually work
transfer learning does work okay why
don't I have one number why do I have a
boxplot again and the answer to that is
you actually why do I have a little
numbers can anybody tell me
yeah cross-validation I use five fold
cross validation that's right
and that's why I have a spread and you
know as usual like the mean is this
black line in the middle the dark line
in the middle and the whiskers show me
the minute match of my of my range so
the recall is really wide like why is my
recall so wide has anybody been to
Kyle's tutorial yesterday yeah on model
validation okay
so yeah like so you probably know again
already my miracle is my butt
raisin ridiculous white is because my
only have a thousand positives it might
in my tests sample and this is really
small
that's like banana distribution is
really wide in here there's a
statistical reason for this but main
thing I wanted to find out here is how
good is the sentence clever neural
network compared to just averaging word
vectors something I would do you know
last year and it seems to the better
like orange is better than red in this
in its graph I mean that's do better
there's some signal here specifically
yeah like in percent is better than just
naive aboard extra averaging but if I do
the guileless calculation from yesterday
this is a slide that I had Todd you know
this morning
there isn't a there's a way that they
can actually be the same is the
confidence intervals actually overlap
because I only have a thousand of
positive cases my range of the recall is
actually like 10% wide and this is
really wide you know like there's a way
maybe they're both you know 89 precision
and 79 recall and that net world I don't
add anything by having this clever
sentence thing I could just be averaging
my glass yeah so this is frustrating
but it just means that I need more data
but it is something that you think about
when you validate models cool any
questions about this no if you don't
have questions the street galas what yes
yeah so the question is what classifier
my using here and the quite surprised
just logistic regression on top on top
of a glove this the same one is I use on
top of in percent so I'm working for a
charity working for a charity is a bit
like working for an open source project
an open source you donate your time and
skills and you get out good tools in the
ecosystem the charity you donate your
skills and time and you get good civil
society in the country to live in
and you sort also benefit from it as
much as a benefit from good potentials
so thanks a lot to these people who came
and volunteered of us for several days
or several weeks and thanks to Andreas
was our main annotator and you know
about his work nothing it would be
possible if you would like to volunteer
us if a company allows you to take two
days off to
to some charity volunteering yeah come
to me I will happily talk about it so
this is my conclusion transmen learning
is really useful it's worked really well
in this task it worked better than
something I spent three days custom
feature engineering and just having a
dead load of downloaded from the
internet it worked better than something
I spent three days custom engineering
that's frustrating you know but this is
progress for you even parts of your job
get automated this is cool machine
learning can make democracy better it
can help us support claims and fact
check them that's not going to make it
perfect you know I'm gonna solve all of
our problems but it will make it better
and if you like to help us come to talk
to me about volunteering or you can
donate at full 500 torques life tonight
yeah thank you if you have any questions
[Applause]
[Music]
the question is about transfer learning
and how can it be in train one domain
how to apply it to another domain for
example Wikipedia and apply it to food
so if you want to do sentiment analysis
and you train on Wikipedia Wikipedia is
dry language there's no emotion in there
you will never achieve anything you know
like model straining Wikipedia have no
emotion
have you read Wikipedia like there's
nothing there there's a lot of emotion
in the debating about editors but
there's no emotion actual article so
that's definitely not going to work you
have to like it's not machine learning
problem you have to put your you know
business analyst head on to understand
if there's actually signal and the data
they've been trained on the data that
interest ana has been training is from
common crawl so just web pages and it
has it's quite varied and it has a lot
of different things in it not just
Wikipedia I think that's why it works
for my data which is the news and the
natural language inference data set as
well like there's a new edition called
multi genre and Ally which doesn't just
use captions but uses other genres to
train it on but it's a very good
question you have to think with your
human head not machine learning head
like he's actually signalling what I
trained on thank you yeah I think it was
a question there
there are organizations which specialize
in future claims they're called think
tanks like this is the job lesson what
you do they predict they try to
influence policy in the future and they
try to have this you know top-down
approach but we don't specialize it
right now there's a lot of claims now
what will happen when believe the U and
all we can report is about current rules
and regulations so what the current laws
and regulations in place but we don't
say what's gonna happen in the future
just tell you from the current legal
framework the what would happen if they
happen today
so that's but they're it's really hard
especially in today's political debate
in the UK thank you yeah yeah
so yeah one of the categories that we
have in here is called the prediction
and that's how we can distinguish in the
future I mean usually they have a
variable in future tense it's not that
hard as an NLP task to talk about to
distinguish is dimension is the future
mentioned or not so bad
yeah this is very important question so
it's the first time I was working with
volunteers not somebody who is paid to
donut ations so I wasn't sure how well
they're gonna do so that's why I said
okay every sentence has to be shown to
five people and if it's free people
agree then that would be a good signal
and it turned out that people who
actually care about full facts enough to
spend the time clicking honest actually
very thoughtful and they spending a lot
of time working on it and I next time I
do it I'll probably let it free is
enough because actually people do it
very carefully much more carefully than
they do to me Chanukah chart for you
know for the minimum wage but it's very
it's very important thing to decide when
do an LP yep
yep
yeah that's a very good question so
glove is a fixed vocabulary technique
once the coupler is fixed and it's been
trained in common curl there's nothing
else that you can do and this is very
strange to me that people at Facebook
use the glove and not fast text because
fast text is much better at working out
of a couple of words fast text is a poor
man's morphology it can it works with
chunks of words like you know three or
four letter contexts inside words and if
they train that and come and crawl and
with that trains infrasound that would
be much better so if you have you know
spare cloud credits should do that
research and publish it and I think it'd
be much better but thanks for the point
uh-huh yeah this has been tried not by
me but by Alex Cano who is the author of
infrasound paper they also tried mean
pulling so try stake in the mean of the
four vectors a lot of people try
conditional random fields on top of it
here and that gives you sometimes half
of one percent better if you can spend a
long time to make it work yeah but the
other techniques we can find this is the
simplest one and that seems to work okay
last question
missions
yep listen this is exactly how we did it
we did it in a newsletter to our
supporters asked who'd like to take part
in the Sanitation task and like I think
about 150 people signed up 90 them 90 of
them actually you logged in and did the
annotation so it was exactly how I went
it's a firm donation people donate then
it
things like 300 men hours that went into
this so far yeah this is how people
support us thank you thank you very much
again for the very interesting talk
[Applause]